- [Mark] All right, Patrick.
Welcome back.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Mark] Yeah, so your last talk
was a very interesting
one because you were
thick in the middle
of a like a week long binge right?
- [Patrick] Yeah, Yeah, I watched it.
I was very high.
- [Mark] Yes you were.
And I thought now would be
a good time to bring you in
'cause now you're clean and sober.
- Clean and sober at the moment,
yeah, it's been a few days
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Since I have been able to get high.
- [Mark] And have you lost your job?
- No.
- [Mark] That's the number one question
everyone's gonna ask you
if you lost your job.
- I haven't lost my job,
I need to, you know,
I need to be responsible
and I need to go to rehab.
I will wind up in rehab soon
and then we'll see what
happens with the job.
I honestly don't care about the job
as much as like my life, you know?
The depression and the...
just the overwhelmingness of this thing
that happens to me that I do is so heavy.
You know, It's so heavy
and there's a lot of
guilt and a lot of shame,
you know, like the idea
of going back to work
and seeing all my people
is hard right now.
- [Mark] Right.
- At this point.
- [Mark] How have you not lost your job?
Because most jobs you'd be fired by now?
- I think the environment
these days is it's...
- [Mark] Did they know
that you had this problem?
- Yeah, they do.
- [Mark] Oh, so they
kind of work with you?
- I mean they want to help me.
They love me.
I love them.
And you know, its like, it's a disease
and it's like a medical disease.
And I always do, like, my best.
Like I use all my effort
to try to stay clean.
So I don't know.
I mean, I haven't really spoken
to any of the managers directly about it.
But they just want what's best for me
and right now what's best
for me is to get help.
And what happens with the
job, it comes down the road.
But I don't think it's as common
as it used to be in the
past to just fire people
especially if they're honest
about what's going on.
So...
- [Mark] And you certainly were honest.
- Yeah. I mean, I was.
Like some of this stuff I said
on there was wow, what the hell?
But it's the truth. That's all.
- [Mark] I mean, what do you think,
I mean, certainly crack
is an addictive substance
but I like to go to the
deeper levels of things
and just to figure out what the core,
the stem of it is, the cause of it.
And is there something
in your self-worth
or something that maybe
is blocking you from.
I kinda see you're intelligent clearly,
and you could...
You must see that this,
if you do this again it'll
lead to more self-destruction.
Eventually you'll be homeless,
losing your employment.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Losing your
income and everything,
and you'll lose your teeth
and you'll lose everything
and maybe your life even.
- Right.
- [Mark] And you're intelligent
enough to know that,
but yet you still repeat this behavior.
- Right. That's what makes
it super frustrating,
even more frustrating than I told...
I absolutely know what's gonna happen.
And eventually I always
wind up doing it anyway.
And that to me, that's
sort of like the definition
of the disease of addiction.
Is that knowing what's going to happen
and it's one thing to be
high and then you can't stop.
You can't stop And then eventually
the drugs get out of your system
and you're sober for a few days.
And then the brain
insists on doing it again.
Insists on doing it again,
even knowing you're
gonna destroy everything.
Just I don't care. I want that feeling.
- [Mark] And intelligence and common sense
won't factor in, right?
- It doesn't factor in
- [Mark] Does like reducing
stress or getting rest
or sleep or anything like that?
- All those things do help.
That those all these sort of
like recovery type things,
which I do, like I said, I do that.
The 12 steps, meditation, exercise.
Like healthy living, you know.
Going after like goals.
I go after all these goals,
but I never get there because
I'm always on another relapse.
And then the relapse
is a destructive thing.
- [Mark] Right.
- And it takes a couple months to at least
to even get back to point
zero and start again.
So yeah, I mean, and the thing
is I kind of hold onto hope.
You know, like I hold onto
hope that this might work now.
You know, like, it might work now.
And God might take away
that broken thing in my brain, you know.
Like the part of my brain
that knowing what's gonna
happen, does it anyway,
that instead of me having
to fight against that.
Because the fight, it's never successful.
It might be successful
on like one or two times,
like, I really wanna do it,
Ah, I'm not gonna do it.
But eventually, it fails.
My own strength always fails.
That's what, like, the idea is
that possibly God will
remove it right off the...
- [Mark] Like a lobotomy?
- Yeah. Like, instead of it coming,
and I fight it and I succeed,
it doesn't come.
That's like the idea of like the 12 steps.
- [Mark] The part of your
brain that triggers it.
- Yeah, that gets removed by
something other than myself.
- [Mark] Right.
- Right, because like,
what's the quote, like
"I can't solve the problem..."
"The same brain that cause a problem,
can't solve the problem."
I think that's an Einstein quote.
And that's what we try to do.
I try to use my crack head brain
to solve my crack head problem.
- [Mark] Yeah, and then
the 12 steps kind of...
- It was designed to
get you into a position
where a god will remove it,
will remove the obsession, they call it.
And I was doing that, you
know, I was doing that.
I was making amends on my nine-step,
which is another kind
of embarrassing thing.
I was going around making, you know,
sort of like apologizing to people
and having like really deep sort of like
beautiful conversations
with people, you know,
that really want the best for me
and be very honest with them.
Like I, like you, could imagine.
And, you know, just a couple of weeks ago,
three, four weeks ago I was doing that.
And here I am, you
know, so it's hard, man.
It's very, very depressing, you know?
Very depressing.
- [Mark] And you've been
through rehab before?
- Yeah, probably 20 times
- [Mark] 20 times.
I wish there was some
solution to this problem.
- Yeah, no, I talked to my dad and he's,
he just, I could tell he just feels so bad
that I have to, like, I
have to have this, you know?
'Cause he says like what
you were saying from,
he says it, he knows me
better than anyone like that.
I have...
I'm great, like, in all the other ways,
like, people love me.
I do good.
I try hard.
I'm nice.
And it's just one thing,
it's this one crippling thing that has now
is like just like a
lifelong anchor and like,
damn it, why did I have
to get this, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah, 'cause
clearly you're a good guy.
You're intelligent.
You have all these great qualities.
- That would have been great.
Why did this have to stick to me?
I don't know.
You know, he feels bad,
people feel bad,
people want to help.
You know, especially
once I do this, you know,
and I'm like sort of in
the aftermath part of it
kinda like right now, I'm so depressed.
Most of the time that I can't
even got to get off the couch.
- [Mark] So I think I may
have asked this last time,
is this a genetic thing or
is it a self-worth thing?
- I mean, self-worth, probably.
I don't know about genetic.
I guess it is genetics.
You know, like it definitely
runs in my family.
Not my parents, but my, you
know, brothers and cousins.
Yeah, self-worth.
My self-worth is zero.
And I was thinking about this recently,
talking to somebody, too, like,
even in between, you know,
like I'll be clean, doing
good, doing 12 steps,
doing my life, going to work, enjoy it.
I'm always, I'm always happy.
I'm always happy.
Like, I'm always like, like
in the moment, like content,
but my self-worth is very low.
- [Mark] Yeah, I go to
a gym every morning.
I do it every day of the year.
And this morning I was there
early in the morning, it's raining.
I have to do it outdoors because of COVID
and it's pouring rain and I'm working out
in the rain with just, you
know, it's freezing cold
and there's a bunch of
other people doing it.
And I was joking with somebody
that the only the reason these people
are so dedicated is most, I would bet you,
half of them have addiction issues.
And they've replaced that
addiction with exercise.
- I was at the gym all the time
and I haven't been since COVID
originally hit, but yeah.
And the gym all the time, like anything,
anything I do, I do at addictively.
Anything.
You know, like, I try
and that's the thing,
that's the thing that I have is that
trying to use my brain
to fix all the problems.
So as soon as I'm clean, that's
one thing that will happen.
Like I'll go to rehab
or I'll get like some time clean
where it's like, okay, I'm gonna be...
And I switch over.
And the depression lifts
and all of a sudden I'm excited
again about being clean.
But the chance not to be stuck
and I'll go on like that
and everything I do, I'll do addictively.
And I'll try to cram 30
hours into a 24 hour day
and I'll feel great.
And everything's like
scheduled and like super anal,
like, super like, you
know, overboard, obsessive,
like, with everything that I'm doing.
I'm trying to be perfect.
Trying to be perfect.
I don't know maybe I get burned out on it.
I don't know.
- [Mark] Are you perfectionist?
- Yes.
- [Mark] You're very
demanding on yourself?
- Yes.
Oh, gosh.
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm sure
there's something there.
- Very much so.
Even to the point of, like,
one thing I have is that I
want everybody to love me.
I think I mentioned that last video.
- [Mark] Yeah, you did.
- I'm always trying to make people laugh.
Like, I'm always making funny comments
and I'll say something and I'll be...
The idea that like, maybe,
like I said something stupid,
will haunt me, like,
for the rest of the day.
- [Mark] Right.
- Like one stupid thing
that nobody cares about,
nobody would even remember,
I'm like stewing it.
Like, Oh, my God.
- [Mark] Right, I think you said
you want everyone to love you
because you don't love yourself.
- Yeah, yeah.
So to think I'm brilliant,
to think I'm, you know, great.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Why people do think that, you know?
- [Mark] I think
acceptance and forgiveness
of ourselves most importantly is probably
at the core of a lot of these problems
you see on my channel.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. True.
And this is because...
- [Mark] An outsider would
say, "You're a great guy."
"You're handsome."
"You're intelligent."
"You seem like great in every way."
- Yeah.
- [Mark] "Just love yourself."
"Don't feel the need to be perfect."
Yeah, that's what someone
would say watching you.
- Like that same person might say,
"Yeah and just stop using drugs."
Like, okay.
Well, thanks for that.
I mean that would work.
Yeah. That would be it.
That would be, you know, like
that would be a good plan.
- [Mark] Yeah, I think loving ourselves
is is the biggest challenge we all have.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Every one of us.
- It's hard for me to even imagine that,
to love myself, you know.
It's hard for me to even imagine.
It's hard right now for me
to imagine ever doing that.
- [Mark] And were you
that way since you...
- I think it's gotten more.
No, I think it's evolved
and grown
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Incrementally over
the years as I continue
to not get through this
because I've been like, try,
like I've been going do
it, like going to rehab
and setting my life up
completely around the goal
of overcoming this since I was 25.
I'm 42.
So when I was 25, it's like, okay, great.
Okay, now I'm clean.
Maybe I'm clean a year.
I started believing in God.
All that was exciting.
You know, I'm 25.
I have a whole, my whole
life in front of me.
Then I got over this crack issue, right?
And then, no.
And then, okay, now I'm
26. Yeah, whatever, like
- [Mark] The older you get,
the more pressure there is to...
- And then no.
And then no, and then no, and then no.
- [Mark] Time is passing.
- Right, and at some point along the way,
like, I get to go to
school and like, you know,
maybe that's a sign of like, you know,
kind of getting getting over the hump
and then no, you know,
and then moving home
and starting to work and,
you know, and then no,
and just, you know.
And I work with all these great people
and just, I know that none
of them do anything like this
and that sometimes I'll be
at work six months clean,
not even thinking and all of a sudden,
I'll just be in the
bathroom and just like,
"Oh, my god, I can't
believe that I'd do this.
I did this six months ago."
- [Mark] No, but it takes
many different forms.
Yours happens to be a crack addiction.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But there are others
who have eating
- Sure.
- [Mark] Disorders
- Yeah.
- [Mark] or gambling
- Yeah
- [Mark] or laziness
- Right.
- [Mark] or getting too low
with their relationships' lives.
- I'm sure.
Everybody has something.
I guess I feel like I need to
focus on mine because I'm me.
And because it's so crazy.
- [Mark] And you're a perfectionist.
- And yeah.
But it's so crazy.
It's so, you know, it's out there,
you know, it's way out there.
- [Mark] Do you think it was something
about the way you were
raised or your childhood?
Or do you think...
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I keep trying to figure out
what the cause of it is.
- I mean, there was that
thing with the molestation,
I guess I never really thought about.
But I always had a thing with sex
like I talked about before.
I don't know, you know, a lot of it...
I do know that a lot
of like male behavior,
like when I'm using is something of a,
something of a like a chase
or a trying to recapture
the very beginning
like when I first discovered all this.
And I don't want it to
be like that, you know,
like I like the idea of it back then
was just so like intriguing.
And so, like, I wanted to do it so bad
and it was more like,
I don't know, it was,
it was more out there back then.
There was no internet, there
was no cell phones back then.
So everything was kinda
like on the streets.
You don't even drive on the streets
and everything's right there.
And so.
- [Mark] Have you talked
to a therapist about this?
- Off and on over the years, I have.
I've had great experiences with therapists
but not obviously
nothing that, you know...
- [Mark] The more of
these interviews I do,
we were talking about this
before the cameras started,
the more I do these, the
more I'm starting to suspect
or fear that we never really change.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] We might improve
a little bit incrementally.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] If we really work hard at it
and have a lot of courage
and forgive ourselves
and all the things that we've mentioned.
But we never really just
all of a sudden become perfectly healthy
and functioning, fully functional.
- I think people do more
than maybe you see down here,
now that I'm thinking
about it a little more,
and I go to AAA meetings and NA meetings.
And there's definitely
people there that are,
even though maybe I
didn't know them before,
you can just tell.
Like the way they are.
- [Mark] They've
straighten their lives out.
- They're just different people.
They're different people altogether.
The way they look at
the world is different.
- [Mark] Yeah, I think
that's what's needed.
- Yeah, and I feel like
maybe I've tasted that
a little bit here and there, you know,
it's like looking at the
world from the angle of,
okay, God is real, first of all.
So like, whatever happens,
I don't have to even worry about it.
Like all this that I
have, I could accept it
and then I won't worry about
it because God is real.
And then going about life
with the number one priority
being to help somebody else.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- There's people that, like, do that
as a practice, as a way of life.
And that's sort of the
goal of those programs
is to build that way of life.
To do little things day by day
and do sort of like work on like,
going back into your own life
and seeing where some of the stuff
that came up through some writing.
And then you're able to like launch out
and be out there helping
other people like me.
And I know dudes like this that are very,
like, very much like that.
They're very like
attractive, you know.
Those are like the guys
that I want to be like.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I like that in my life.
- [Mark] And I know that people do change.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I've known them in my life.
- [Mark] People that have really
made that huge transformation.
- Yeah, but it has to be sort
of like, along those lines.
I think you might be right.
Like, people like me,
we don't just change ourselves.
I mean, if we don't do anything,
it's definitely, nothing's
gonna change, you know.
For me even doing a lot,
it seems like nothing.
- [Mark] And for some
people, it's religion
and for other people, it's like exercise
or something extreme.
- Yeah.
But, to me, I think that
helping others' peace
is a huge part of it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Like not living for
myself 'cause that's...
At the core of this thing is very selfish.
Like, drug addiction is a selfish thing.
It just is.
And so like the antidote to selfishness
is to like not think of yourself at all.
To be like, "What can I
do for the next person?"
"How can I help this person."
You know, so...
- [Mark] And if that's the case,
do you think it's courage
to not be selfish or to do things
that you've never done before
or something like that?
To me, courage is a big part of all this.
- I mean, courage, I think
courage comes along the way.
- [Mark] It's not
determination and discipline.
- A little bit, a little
bit of it is discipline.
Not so much discipline not to use,
but discipline to do the right thing.
Discipline to, you know,
get up in the morning
and like sort of start the day,
thinking a lot, thinking about it
in those sort of the natural way.
- [Mark] Yeah, no, I mean...
- What can I do today?
How can I help somebody else today?
- [Mark] Certainly, discipline, support.
- Yeah, and just to be committed to that.
And I mean, the times I've had a few like,
opportunities to help
people like even directly
through sponsoring in the 12
steps or that sort of thing
or just even talking about it.
Whenever I do, I feel better.
Like whenever I do, I
feel like, I feel great.
Like it's a good feeling.
And I wasn't even seeking that feeling,
I was just trying to
help the other person.
So,
that's a thing,
but there is always the big question
like why isn't it sticking?
- [Mark] That's where I'm suspicious.
That maybe courage is the answer.
Whereas, if you just
started doing some helping
- [Patrick] Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] And maybe dug in deeper
and even helped further on a deeper level
- [Patrick] Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Really committed to it.
- [Patrick] Yeah.
- [Mark] Then your self
perception would change so...
- [Patrick] It could be.
- [Mark] So deeply, so profoundly
that you would no longer
feel any shame.
- [Patrick] Yeah.
- [Mark] If the shame would disappear.
- [Mark] Shame's a big,
shame's a huge factor.
- [Patrick] Oh, yeah. Crippling.
- [Mark] I mean, if you were
to consistently do things
that would make it impossible for you
to see yourself as anything other than
altruistic and kind and a good person
where you're helping others relentlessly,
wouldn't that impact your
self-worth significantly?
- [Patrick] Yeah, I think that's true.
Maybe I just haven't gotten
deep enough into it yet.
Well, maybe like,
if I could get past
six months, nine months
without a relapse happening
and continue on the path
that I've been on, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
Because whether it's
drug addiction or sex work or whatever,
whatever your vice is, it creates shame.
- [Patrick] Yes.
- [Mark] If you can do something
that really erases that shame
and usually helping another
is a great way to do that
but what better way, right?
- [Patrick] Right.
- [Mark] Then all of a sudden,
your shame disappears.
And without the shame, then,
that was your number one
factor why you're doing
this self-destructive
stuff in the first place.
- [Patrick] Yeah.
- [Mark] So, you're thinking of rehab now?
- Yeah. That's what I,
That's what I should do.
That's what, you know, that's...
the clear thing that I should do.
I'm considering going to the East coast
where I have some friends.
Or probably here, I haven't decided where.
And just try again.
I guess what my mom says is, "Try again.
What can you do except try again?"
And it's like all the other options,
you know, I don't know, would be like...
Die?
Get homeless?
I've never really been homeless.
I don't know if I could hang on that.
And
- [Mark] Yeah, I think the helping thing
is probably something that...
- It's back to that.
Yeah. I mean, it's pitiful.
Like this whole thing is just pitiful.
I'm getting old.
I don't really care, you know,
I was talking to my dad about this, too.
Like, I don't really care, like,
prestige or position or money
has never really been like the motivator,
like the driving factor for
me to be happy or content.
Like I've been in
long-term rehab situations
where I've had like pretty much no money.
And I was totally happy.
I was just as happy as I'll
be here working, you know.
Every, any situation that I ever am in.
if I'm clean and being
productive, that I'm content.
And I, so, I don't know, you know.
I don't know, like I mentioned
teen challenge last time.
Teen challenge is where I
had the longest, you know,
the most, probably highest percentage
of days clean in a stretch.
But a lot of that was
because I was living there.
You like live there and help
work there with the students
- [Mark] That you were helping.
- But maybe that's what it...
Maybe I'm just not cut out for it.
Maybe I need to go somewhere like that
and just stay for the rest of my life.
And people do that.
Wouldn't be the end of the world.
And I would be helping people.
I would probably be happy.
But I wouldn't have any
money, but who cares?
You know?
- [Mark] Wow.
Yeah, the older I get, the more I think
that there are alternative paths in life
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That can lead to
happiness and fulfillment.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Then what society
- Right.
- [Mark] says you're supposed to do.
- Yeah, and I'll probably be...
I would be very very helpful to people
- [Mark] I'm sure you will.
- If I get my act together.
- [Mark] I can totally
see you doing great things
for yourself and for others.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Very clearly.
- [Mark] But we all
need to get out of this
- Yeah.
- [Mark] quick sand that you're in here.
Yeah, now's the time.
- [Mark] Absolutely.
Well, Patrick, I wish you the best of luck
with whatever you do.
- Thanks, Mark.
- [Mark] And maybe we'll
do this again one day.
- Yeah, let's do it again,
you know, down the road
and see the difference, you know,
there's definitely a difference.
You'll see a difference between me.
I'm not high compared to last time
but if you catch me three months clean,
you'll see the difference
between this and that for sure.
- [Mark] Oh, I'd love to see you again.
That'd be great.
- All right.
- [Mark] All right.
Thank you very much.